hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
as much the 27th and you're watching
games what needs warm lads the handsome
collection brought Borderlands to end a
pre sequel to current gen recently but
unfortunately not everything has gone to
plan a number of players have reported
issues with screen tearing and
stuttering frame rates that's not a good
thing for gamers who purchased the
collection hoping for graphically
superior versions of the original title
Gearbox Software have owned up to the
issues today with community developer
joking saying the team is certainly
aware of both the screen tear and FPS
lag issues and are currently
investigating them needless to say
things are quite busy and we appreciate
everyone's continued patience our
reviewer Cameron Rothley noted that
while indoors games are unlikely to
notice the framerate drops performance
hits are quite common in big battles and
large detailed areas batman arkham
knight might not be out yet but i can
tell you a bunch of details about the
holy Quinn DLC so here's the info on
that the expansion which is available to
people who pre-order Arkham Knight will
let players step into the stylish yet
affordable groups of Harley Quinn and
quote wreak havoc inside the blood Haven
Police Department the DLC pack story
takes place before the events of Arkham
Knight and revolves around Quinn search
for poison ivy with in Bludhaven extra
content will include for challenge maps
and the utilization of Holly's unique
weapons gadget and abilities finally
it's not the hard life story that you
want but half-life 2 is getting a
remaster which you can play on steam
very
the remaster comes in the form of a free
fan-made update which are the new visual
effects improved lighting and world
detail as well as a lot of bug fixes and
a community commentary mode project lead
Phillip Victor has said that the
remaster upgrades half-life 2 to the
same graphical quality as its episodic
sequels you can watch the updates
trailer and comparison video to check
out all the improvements on gamespot let
me know down in the comment if you're
going to play a half-life 2 update and
why or why not you can head to gain salt
we've got a trailer for halo online and
use on the ps4 latest update those are
all the good things from today be sure
to leave me your thoughts and pop back
same time tomorrow for the five best
stories of the whole gaming week